something that happens is you have to
surround yourself by peers in a space
too who understand you and don't see you
as competition yeah that's really hard
and it's like a fine line I genuinely
believe that collaboration wins always
so I my whole approach to most things
has always been hey I want to
collaborate with you whether I'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media I'm just like I just want to work
together because I think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success in numbers but
more in terms of I want to be friends
with you and so I reach out regularly to
people that I admire in different ways
and I reach out to them and say hey I'd
love to get to know you I'd love to
learn from you I'd love to connect I'd
love to be a friend like not I'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this and
if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that I've just got a great friend
who now gets me so I try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
I feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do are just so great because they
already get you someone that I had on my
podcast lately her name is Lily Singh
Superwoman uh she's become a recent
friend she's been incredibly and is
incredibly successful on social media
she's using our platform for doing
amazing good in the world and she was
someone I reached out to because I was
just like hey like you've been doing all
of this for a while you started on
YouTube a lot longer than I did and I
would just love to connect from you and
hear from you and she's become an
incredible friend and we've just been
sharing ideas and learning together and
it's like that relationship's awesome
and then at the same time I'm trying to
find people who are not in media so I
still have friendships with the monks
back in India and I just spent January
in India for a month I was meditating
again for for roughly about 21 days and
I have them in my life because they
remind me of like the roots and they
remind me of the truths that bring me
back so I kind of like both I love
people who totally get my space and
usually those are people I reach out to
and then I love having my roots down so
most of my inner circle now is from
people I've reached out to or they
become people who've been reaching out
to me for a long long time and have been
consistently reaching out to me asking
for nothing the reason why you're not
following through is because you're
doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely but this is
the life of an entrepreneur this is why
so many great entrepreneurs don't follow
through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it but I have a really low
maybe it's just introverted or or
whatever but I just don't need it as
much as most people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you
know you get to pick everything you want
but then to go from having a job where
you have Community even if it even if
you didn't enjoy the work you were doing
which you got from the job if you've had
one is community that you had co-workers
and you had some people who you did like
and you had people to go to lunch with
and you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
no you're great yeah you just tore my
heart open Evan now what do I do how do
I fix it well first it's just
recognizing that that is a problem you
know first is recognizing that there's
nothing wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with you you're amazing the only
problem is you just don't have anybody
that you're collaborating with that
you're doing this by yourself so the
answer is we need to now go and find
other people to collaborate with so one
recognizing that this is a problem and
you need to fix it two is in finding a
group that you can be a part of and what
we tend to do as entrepreneurs is lead
we want to lead we want to create groups
we want to build we want to make
oh
I would actually advocate for joining a
group
one you don't need another thing on your
plate to lead you've got enough already
that you have to worry about and two
when you're the leader of it it puts you
in a slightly different position where
it's nice just to participate
you know it's nice just to have somebody
else be in charge and you just get to
show up
and and be a part of it
so I would look for a community that you
could join
where it's where it's your people it's
people like you who are trying to do
similar things
I look at movement makers as an example
and whether you want to join Movie
Makers or or you know find your own
group amazing but movement makers I
started
as a way for me to help train
up and coming thought leaders you know
it was the initial goals like hey I can
only reach I want to tell the world's
biggest problem right people don't
believe in themselves enough not
everybody's gonna learn through my story
but they might be able to learn through
yours your message your story your
history your way of looking at it the
thing that you went through I haven't
gone through until that by definition
allows you to reach people that I can't
that Tony Robbins can't that Jay Shetty
can't that whoever Oprah can't right
your story can reach people in a way
that others can't and so I want to give
you the skills to be able to go off and
reach those people that's why I started
Movie Makers what I realized getting
through it is the skills alone Aren't
Enough the skills are not the main
reason why people are not following
through
you already have a lot of skills you
know it's not where you want to be but
you have a lot of skills and you have a
lot of heart so if you take somebody
with a lot of skills and a lot of heart
and they're still not following through
what's the problem
Community you're doing it alone
you're lonely and it's really hard to do
it when you're lonely so I shifted
movement makers to still BS skills and
training and techniques and strategies
and I realize that people are winning
when they connected to each other
and at the start I was doing all the
connection like oh I know this person's
doing this and this person's doing that
and so I should connect those two people
together
and I was and that was creating that's
created businesses it's created podcasts
together that's created opportunities
for people but it still was limited on
me connecting people together where I
wanted to make it that people
would connect to each other without me
and that's what we've ended up doing in
Movie Makers
um one of the things I'm most proud of
is we started a challenge and again
whether I don't care if you draw Movie
Makers or not great to have you but this
concept you can apply to your business
we started a challenge where
I was giving people the tactics and
telling them what to do and that they
still weren't doing a follow-through and
the follow-through would be making
content making videos right you want to
be a thought leader you got to get your
message out there
so I started a challenge and we started
the first one I think back in October so
now we're into our fifth Challenger so
where here's the challenge you have to
make one video
one lead magnet and three collaboration
videos around the theme so the theme
might be momentum or impact or believe
or belong
um we pick a different theme every month
but something everybody can talk to
right the theme was impact you can talk
the impact within the thing that you do
and by forcing them to collaborate with
three other people in the group
it really led to a situation where one
plus one equals a thousand
because
by forcing yourself to show up for
somebody else
and made sure that you followed through
where all of a sudden now people who who
hadn't made a single video who might
have been a movie makers for three
months and still never made a video now
they're making their first videos now
they're making the first League magnets
now they're making their first solo
videos suddenly they have
some follow-through
and suddenly the fears and the excuses
will weigh because they're connected to
other people when you're doing something
with somebody else there's energy there
there's momentum there and you're much
more likely to follow through
so you have to go and get a tribe
find people who are like you who have a
similar Mission if you look at mover
makers
everybody's mission is is different in
the sense that they're trying to serve
different people but everybody's
connected in that we want to have an
impact we have a story that matters and
we want to share it with the world
that's everybody in the group
the types of people trying to reach are
different and so when you are
by yourself you're the only one in your
family trying to do what you do you're
the one pouring into other people right
you're probably the most happy
optimistic positive person you're
encouraging the people around you you're
pouring into their cups great keep doing
that but who's helping you with that
when you feel low when you feel down
when you feel not worthy when you feel
not good enough who's pouring in you
they say hey let's go do this thing
together
nobody right your friends maybe I mean
if you're lucky and you have some great
friends might be empathetic might be
encouraging in you but they're not doing
the thing that you're doing they don't
understand what you're going through
they could they could give you some
words of affirmation and encouragement
but they don't know how to actually help
where if you're going through a journey
with somebody else with a group of
people you're just much more likely to
follow through
and feel connected
and feel special and feel like you
matter
so Step One is recognize that there's
nothing wrong with you
you're amazing you've got the heart
you've got the dream you've got the the
ability to serve
on step two is then to go find your
tribe go find people who are like you
who you see on your calendar
and you're excited to go meet with them
and connect
whether it's Movie Makers or something
totally separate
but don't do this alone
if you could make one change this year
for the next 12 months
to have the significant impact on the
growth of your journey
commit to just not doing this by
yourself
and watch everything in your life get
better
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I read this amazing quote by Richard
Branson that says we don't stop playing
because we get old but we get old
because we stop playing and I realized
in the pandemic just how much I loved to
play whether it was a game of Catan
whether it was a game of tennis I just
knew that I had to be more active
mentally and physically with the value
of play now often play scene is
something that should be reserved
through the weekends it's seen as
something that you put off as a treat
well why can't we break it down and
treat ourselves in the middle of a day
maybe it's playing a game of cards maybe
it's playing a video game if you just
want to take that break to beat your
next record or maybe it's just doodling
or messing around or calling up a friend
and having a playful conversation the
point is that play can be used as a
reward As a treat throughout the day you
don't have to put it off now for those
people that can be quite addictive
personalities like me and find that if
you turned on a video game at 2PM you
may still be paying it at 10 P.M and set
a timer before you start allow yourself
to get that one game of FIFA or NBA 2K
in like I would and then get back to
work doing something fun and exciting
can increase blood pressure dopamine and
your heart rate giving you the energy
boost you need talk about Detachment I'm
just like that that I think is is one of
the hardest things that we face today it
is 100 and and one of the ways we were
trained and I'm not I'm not recommending
this to anyone watching I'm just sharing
how how much we are obsessed and
addicted to the body we were trained to
not look in the mirror oh wow so we
didn't I didn't look in a mirror for
like three years wow right like no way
effectively yeah as you know I looked at
him right now again when I shaved my
head or like whatever like right but you
don't look in the mirror to look at your
appearance
I'm not saying that I don't recommend
that before you go to work tomorrow or
anything like that but just listen to
the principles you're gonna get a uh
yeah
what do I look like
so the reason is and that's the reason
why monks have shaved heads too because
you focus Less on your physical
appearance you spend less time on your
physical appearance what that allows you
to do is it literally dissolves your
understanding of your physical presence
which means all you have to deal with is
the inside
just think about how much attention it
takes to keep ourselves well groomed to
take care of ourselves to our ego and
attachment to how good we look at it and
I have it too right we all have it like
I'm not saying I'm detached from that
but what I'm saying is that we were
trained in the belief that if you're
able to switch off and close your eyes
why don't we close our eyes when we
meditate right it's because it detaches
us from the physical presence of where
we are so that we can go inside I feel
like we give we give our toxic
relationships and negativity so much
energy
where like cons like for example in your
comments section on Instagram for anyone
who's on social media for everyone who's
on social media
you could pinpoint the one negative
comment out of a hundred positive
comments and we all do it we amplify the
negative and you see all the time and we
do the same in our lives where we sit
here talking about all the toxicity and
so for me it's like I can either spend
all my energy trying to convince that
one person to love me or I can reply to
the people that love me already and
they'll love me more because they are
already engaging and they're going to
feel so happy that I responded to them
and I think this is a great simple tip
for everyone who's listening it's just
when you respond to positivity in your
life it just increases when you respond
to the negativity in your life it just
increases and so trying to get someone
to like you and defend yourself and
control how they feel about you it
wastes and drains so much energy and you
could use all that energy for the people
that love you when we were put out on
the streets with nothing nothing that
had to fend for ourselves and you
recognize how you connect your live with
very little and how you need very little
to get by whether it was fasting and
like not being able to eat for several
days or drink for several days you
recognize how grateful you are for what
you do have and so these many
experiments that are very extreme that
I'm not saying anyone has to do or I'm
not recommending anyone at home to do
them all I'm trying to say is that the
body is like a vehicle we have to care
of it just as you have a nice car you've
got to take care of that nice car but if
you don't feed the driver that car's not
going anywhere and so many of us have
become more addicted to the vehicle than
we have to the driver inside and it's
the way of tapping into that driver
inside is spend time with people who
know their driver really well and that's
why monks are such a big part of my
growth because you meet people who have
no agenda want nothing from you want
nothing of the world and are not trying
to get somewhere like there's no there's
no win-win it's only wind for you like
there's no winning it for them and and
being around the energy of realized
people who have that realization who've
been with their Consciousness for 10 20
30 40 years that's a huge part of it
we're being built for a job or we're
being built to be in a box right we're
being built so that we fit into society
and I find it funny right it's like when
you're a kid you're told to fit in like
what you probably remember this stay in
line yeah they fit in yeah everyone has
to wear a uniform everyone dresses the
same everyone has to do this and then
when you grow older what are we all
trying to do we're all trying to stand
out it's weird it's like your whole life
you were told to fit in and then as soon
as you grow older it's like oh you need
a personal brand now you need to stand
out like do you know your own voice you
need to stand out how do you deal with
it when the doubt is coming from the
people that you really love and you know
they care about you yeah it was hard I
didn't go to my graduate I graduated but
never went to my graduation ceremony so
my mom doesn't have a picture of me
holding my degree and that was a big
thing for her because I moved to India I
just went so I never went to band that
was a big thing for her and actually my
parents I'm very grateful my mom and dad
are actually fairly liberal and
supportive of anything I've decided to
do it's my my extended family that's had
more opinions and been more involved in
kind of stirring stuff up with my
parents if that makes sense so the way I
dealt with it was always asking myself
these questions around you know is
someone invested in my future
is someone going to be there for me when
I'm struggling and there's someone
paying my bills like those are my three
checking system of food matters in life
like your soul your mind and your
paycheck and I think the biggest thing I
asked myself was just am I going to look
back if I don't do this am I going to
look back going back to the Alexander
the Great story am I going to look back
on my deathbed and say
my Mom and Dad held me back
because I may say I'm going to do it for
them I'm not going to do this decision
because I respect them and love them but
am I going to hate them in the end or be
bitter towards them or feel a negative
feeling towards them because I feel they
held me back and if that's the truth I
never want to feel that about my parents
they're incredible so I need to go and
take the responsibility to make this
shift
and I think the truth is that when we
think people are holding us back it's
just us not taking responsibility for us
to push forward like that's all it is
because the truth is if you really
really really really really really want
something right like if someone told you
right now you had to get on a plane and
there's a million dollars in New York no
one would say oh my parents can't afford
a place like no one would say that you
would do it if you really wanted it
you'd get on a plane right now and you'd
go pick that million dollars up so it's
our own insecurity that we reflect onto
the people around us and I think it's
really important I get it there are
people who are toxic around us I get it
I had that too there were people who
were just like literally people said to
me like you realize you're going to fail
at being a monk you realize when you
come back No One's Gonna hire you you
realize when you come back no one's
going to want to be with you you really
you know there are so many things like
people like you know you're going to be
socially Dead Like No One's Gonna care
where you are there was so much of that
but it didn't get Amplified because I
was strong in my conviction so the way I
dealt with it was just keeps
strengthening your conviction rather
than trying to weaken the argument
because the the opinions of others will
get weakened when you strengthen your
own right that's how it works you don't
weaken someone else's to strengthen your
own we're so used to in our life having
instant judgment defining a moment and
giving it a label good or bad in the
moment and I thought how do I present a
concept to the world where we can laugh
at ourselves and realize that sometimes
our instant judgment or our instant
labeling processor isn't always correct
yes how do we how do we get that so this
script or narrative that I shared in
this video is on a gentleman who goes to
buy these cookies because he feels like
having a few cookies because his
flight's delayed and he sits down to eat
these cookies and the gentleman opposite
him where you're sitting right now
starts to take cookies out as well and
he's thinking how's this guy and the guy
looks a little rugged he looks a little
scruffy he doesn't look put together so
naturally all of our biases our
unconscious biases start coming up and
stemming up we start thinking oh he
looks a little shady and maybe he
doesn't have money that's why he's
taking my cookies and we have this
impression of I me and mine these are my
cookies how can he take them only to
realize when he leaves that your cookie
box was in your bag and that gentleman
was sharing his cookies with you and
then this person has this Epiphany or
this moment of realizing how quick he
was to judge but how wrong he was and I
think all of us in different ways have
different moments in our life where
whether we misjudged a person the first
time we met them or we misjudged someone
because the first thing they said to us
or we had a friend that now is our best
friend but our first impression was oh
they're a loser and all of a sudden now
we think they're amazing emotional
intelligence to me is being able to be
aware of yourself self-awareness being
able to know yourself that's the highest
form of EQ right like being able to say
I know when I'm at my best I know when I
struggle and I know when this is a
limiting belief or not and then being
able to process all of that so we're not
helping people
we I love saying this because it it
simplifies it but we teach people what
to think not how to think right we tell
them two plus two is four but we don't
tell them how to think about a problem
and that's why when you're faced with a
new problem
and you don't have a formula for it and
you don't have an equation for it you're
like oh I'm stuck right and life's like
that like when in life have you used a
formula to solve a real situation in
life even business yeah like when
there's a formula helped you yeah but
we're taught that formulas solve
equations but we all know that there's
no formula to business success happiness
meaning
etc etc etc I literally skip over
negative comments genuinely since day
one and I remember reading in those
times so I'll add this there have been
times when I've looked at negative
comments and they're like Ah that's
quite funny like you know it's really
funny they're true but overall I try to
respond to everyone who said something
positive and I rarely put any energy
into put anyone who put anything
negative because I don't want to change
their mind they're entitled to their
belief they're okay to feel that way and
if I feel like it's good feedback I'll
take it on board but if I feel like it's
just someone being a keyboard Warrior
and you know doesn't like me and saying
what they want then I'm not going to
take that seriously yeah it's pretty
easy to tell all the difference between
the two 100 if there's some authenticity
and truth behind it it's a much
different comment than just unabashed
hate yeah absolutely and I've had
everything from he has a wind machine in
his videos to make sure his hair flies
right like I've had that that angle but
you don't I don't I just went out on a
really windy day this is exclusive on
the podcast this is an exclusion of the
podcast I do not have a wind machine but
I have everything from that and I
laughed at that I thought that was a
hilarious comment through to the other
side of just like you know I don't agree
with you and I don't agree with the
point you're making this is my point and
I'm like yeah you know what I had three
minutes to explain that and I missed
that point like you're right you know I
agree with you if I had a podcast like
this I could have explained myself
so you know I but I do think that we do
drag our own selves down we put all the
energy into the negativity and amplify
it another story I tell you because I
love this too and it shows so and and
he'll like this story so Marcus Aurelius
if you haven't read meditations by
Marcus Aurelius highly recommend it
Marcus Aurelius Emperor meditations is
his personal Journal
and one of the stories that I love about
him that that comes up in a few
Hollywood movies too is that once when
he was walking walking through the Roman
Town Square he used to have his advisor
follow him around and whenever people
would glorify him and praise him the
person's job was to come into his ear
and Whisper you're just a man you're
just a man just to remind him just to
remind him in that moment where you just
you know in that moment where you just
feel like your egos is going through the
roof because everyone's saying you're
amazing you changed my life Etc a to
remember you're just a man and I would
add to that remember the people who made
you that right remember the people who
gave you that and so that's how I've
learned to balance ego is by any time
i'm glorified or praised or appreciated
or recognized I'm passing that off to my
teachers guides mentors the universe and
accepting it on their behalf
so if I receive an award I actually
don't think it's mine I'm accepting it
on behalf of everyone who made me the
way I am it's beautiful whether it was
positive or negative too one of my
favorite thoughts from Martin Luther
King is if you want a new idea read an
old book what old books
uh many different ones the Bhagavad
Gates is probably one of my favorite
books it's it's been such a huge part of
my personal journey and personal life
many other religious texts as well so
the Bible has been a big part of my
study spent a lot of time with the Bible
and and then it can just be thoughts and
ideas even if the last 2000 years so
historicism a huge fan of Marcus
Aurelius meditations that's been a huge
book for me that I've studied and
sometimes old can just mean 50 years or
100 years ago too but those are some of
the bigger ideas that I think have had
more prominent effects in my life so
Vedic and stoic knowledge has probably
been the most influential after a long
time the other day my friends and I went
bowling and I started to think to myself
that life is a lot like
bowling is a team sport just like life
in Bowling Sometimes the best players
struggle and others that were less
likely to do well surprise you and make
all the difference this is one of my
favorite lessons focusing on someone
else's score doesn't make yours any
better it's easy to get distracted by
how well someone else is playing you see
their score go up they bowl a strike or
a spare you're calculating in your mind
what you think that could be but all
that does is it distracts you from your
game similarly in life focusing on
someone else's Instagram grid doesn't
make yours any better focusing on what
someone else is doing for work or what
they're driving doesn't make yours any
better focus on yourself focus on your
own role your strengths that will make
all the difference I'm able to not judge
myself because I don't judge others a
lot of people who are like a lot of
right so tell me I don't know I'm just
powerful no I love that that's such a
great Point how do you think that's such
a great point no you're spot on because
the reason why we have we judge others
is because we judge ourselves right the
opposite of what you're saying and so
for me it's the same thing the reason
why I don't expect is because I see
everything as my responsibility I see
everything as my work yes and I see
everything else as a bonus yeah like
it's just amazing that anyone even cares
about me or has time for me or makes an
effort to do something or connect me to
someone whatever it is and that's just a
beautiful bonus of life but I've got to
be in charge of it and I think that just
came from many years of having
expectations I think that came from
times when I did expect and I didn't get
and I realized I don't want to feel this
way anymore I always talk about there's
two types of create well there's three
types of creatives but we usually end up
one of the two so there's the sellout
Creator a sellout Creator only goes with
what the audience wants so you literally
forget about anything you care about or
believe in you just go for what you
think is going to get likes and then the
opposite is the selfish Creator who only
creates for themselves they're like I
think this is amazing like I'm the
funniest person in the world or I'm the
deepest person or whatever it is and you
create something and like no one wants
to watch it because you literally made
it for you and your mum like you know
it's kind of like sits there and so I
always aim for being in the middle I
recognize that I want to stand for what
I believe in but I also want it to
connect and resonate and have a positive
impact on other people's lives so that's
my starting point that every piece of
content should be true to me but it
should resonate with people it should
make a difference I set a goal very
early on that my videos were only 75
complete and I say this everywhere
actually I've never said it often I've
never said it on a podcast but I've said
it often on stage in the events my
videos are only 75 complete which means
I mess words up often so you'll see that
sometimes my sentence wasn't perfect I
mispronounced a word I developed a lisp
on a word because it was in flow and I
said it and it wasn't right but it felt
outright and other things where I
finished a shoe and we forgot a shot
that was huge for the video but I'm like
it's all right 75 so my goal with every
video is 75 and I've had to do that
because I've realized that if I wait for
75 to 99 I'll be waiting for a year and
a half or three years
right and we released three videos a
week right now and so for me the goal
was always 75 and I love that yeah and I
personally think that's a great aim
because 75 is realistic it's quality so
you're not settling for less but 75 to
99 is such a long journey I really
started to get fascinated in my teens my
father became very spiritual when I was
10 years old and I actually saw that as
very weird because why did he do that I
think he went through now when I look
back on hindsight he went through his
sort of like midlife crisis journey
search at the age of 40 where he was
married had two kids had a decent job in
the city but didn't feel satisfied and
didn't feel fulfilled and so he went off
and I was 10 years old he went on in his
search so he went from everything from
Reiki and healing to Church of
Scientology through to all the religious
truths I was just searching for answers
and when he did that that was actually
quite alien and weird for me and my
family because we thought oh he's just
gone mad because I guess it was my first
experience of what a midlife crisis or
midlife Journey looks like so that
actually deterred me from spirituality
because it was almost like he was
letting the family down and it was tough
for my mom and all the rest of it so
that was that was kind of how my teens
were spent but then I got fascinated by
it because I remember it was one
Christmas and we used to celebrate
Christmas every year we used to wrap
presents have a Christmas tree and one
year I just felt like a hypocrite I was
just like I don't know anything about
Jesus and I don't know much about
Christianity I was about 15 years old
and I was like but we celebrate
Christmas like why do we celebrate
Christmas so then I started I remember I
went to church that year on Christmas
Day and Christmas Eve just because I
felt like a hypocrite and I felt that I
should at least understand or try and
take an interest in what I was doing
we've all had the story and I'm just
sharing it again to give context we've
all had the story of the two wolves or
the two dogs however you want to phrase
them if you haven't I'll tell it now
it's it's a story of how inside of us
there are two dogs two wolves and
they're fighting for Supremacy so inside
you one is the initial and one is the
responde
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator so your
initiating wolf is strong powerful bulky
aggressive because it's been fed well
your whole life
and your responsive dog your responsive
wolf has not been fed has not been
listened to and so it's weak and feeble
and meek and humble and doesn't even
stand to fight so when they too come to
fight inside of you this this Wolf's
just going to eat that wolf right up and
that's what's happening right now so for
all of us whatever two wolves you're
seeing whether it's your mind and your
intelligence whether it's your intuition
versus what your parents say whether
it's expectations of society versus your
expectations of yourself like whatever
two wolves you have inside of you the
one that wins is the one you feed and
the ones you have been feeding now if
you're at a point where you are in and
where I am and where all of us are in
different scenarios of our life where
we're trying to shift and start feeding
the other one it's hard because the
other one's just been fed more it's
stronger it's able to push you it's able
to dictate you and this is where
detachment's okay that Detachment
doesn't mean that you owe nothing
Detachment means that nothing owns you
and most of us have become owned by our
darker walls most of us have become
owned by the self that we don't want so
so that conditioning has been drawn up
the only way to break it is to disrupt
the pattern to really break that it has
to be and this is why I talk to people
about immersive experiences like you
meditating for 10 minutes a day on a
headspace that's wonderful and I
recommend it but that's not going to
shift this in a drastic way you are
going to have to go and spend a week out
in Joshua Tree with this Shaman you are
going to have to take a break in
Jerusalem right we were both in love
with Jerusalem like instead of going on
a holiday this year you are going to
have to go on a three-day intensive
transformative Retreat and the reason
why I'm saying all these different
things is they all have different
budgets they're all available in
different countries you don't have to go
to India and live with monks but you
have to do something and it has to be
immersive because when you get immersed
in something then then you're giving
something the power to break your
pattern right and I think the challenge
is we're trying to solve it by a little
thing every day which is a good start to
get us going but if you're really
serious about a massive shift in your
life wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah you need to go
water that you need to go feed it you
need and you need to go give it energy
and that's what I think
we find that and that that's what I
think people struggle they still want to
go on their Beach holiday
they're like no I can't give that up I
need that our this weekend I still need
to go and do up my house and it's like
well no like just imagine what would
happen if this weekend you just went on
a three-day Retreat that changed your
life like imagine if you just gave that
energy in terms of finding your purpose
that seems like it's the first step is
getting comfortable with yourself
understanding that how do we take that
next step towards finding that purpose
yeah so for me I I Define it as your
passion is for you your purpose is for
others so your purpose is when you use
your passion to serve others that's the
the link so for me the focus actually
first becomes what's your passion like
what are you passionate about what do
you enjoy doing and then the miss the
parts that that's usually Miss so
everyone hears Follow Your Passion find
your passion it's like a cliche it's
everywhere the difference is get really
good at it
like get so good at it and everyone
always misses that point you can be as
passionate as you want about tennis
but if you're not really good at tennis
No One's Gonna care and No One's Gonna
Take No and I think that's often miss
that not only do you need to find what
you're passionate about you need to turn
it into an expertise which is undeniable
and that requires the hard work that
requires the work ethic that requires
the early mornings that requires the
training in whatever field you want to
be
and then and that's going to make you
successful
so when you figure out your passion and
you get really good at it you're going
to become successful but you're only
going to be happy when you use that
success to help other people and then
you've got to figure out that link to
purpose so you're going to find your
purpose so when you realize hey I'm
really good at this I love it I get a
lot of Happiness from doing it when you
start using that to make a difference in
other people's lives in any way it
automatically switches into a purpose so
you don't need to find your purpose it's
just an automatic evolution of finding
your passion and being really good at it
and that's where we're messing up that
we haven't found something we love and
we haven't found something that we love
that we've got really good at so what we
usually do with our lives is we do
things that we're not good at and don't
love right or we do things that we're
good at but don't love and we need to
switch into the spaces of things that we
love but are not good at and get really
good at them and start finding out
things that you are good at and you do
love there's different ways to play the
game
some people spin the ball some people go
for a straight direct role some people
use two or three fingers the list
continues and the truth is it's exactly
the same in our lives you will see some
people succeeding in a certain way and
others doing it completely differently
the goal is to find your way your method
your approach the direction that works
for you without trying to copy or mimic
or imitate someone else and we've all
experienced this sometimes your ball
ends up in the gutter I'm sure you've
had that before sometimes your throw was
completely out of control and your ball
went directly into the gutter or maybe
sometimes you actually felt well
prepared and confident but the balls
still ended up in the gutter in life
just like that ball sometimes we feel
we're in the gutter but there's
something to learn from that and just
like the ball comes back when we learn
through our experience we get another
opportunity to improve another
opportunity to try another opportunity
to succeed as Oscar Wilde said all of us
are in the gutter but some of us are
looking up at the stars sometimes you
hit a spare you threw your best shot you
got the angle perfectly right you
prepared with everything you had
and that one pin is still up there
sometimes despite our best efforts in
life
we don't get what we want
not everything aligns everything doesn't
go to plan life is a lot like bowling
keep your eyes on the ball your
concentration in the game and your mind
out of the gutter and in the end we
realize we have to be just like that
bowling pin no matter how hard we're hit
by life no matter how hard we're hit by
others we have to keep stepping back up
that has happened so many times when a
video you think's gonna hit and it
doesn't and then there's a video you're
like that's never gonna hit and it does
and that's where I've reconciled myself
that
is recognizing that I don't always know
what's going to work and that's a
beautiful thing and that I've been and I
and I've been feeling this often that
I've got to where I want in life just
not in the way I imagined it
and that's the beauty of giving up that
control and feeling slightly liberated
so I'll give an example of what I mean
by that I'm always working strategically
effectively and impactfully in the best
ways I can but sometimes the place where
I put my most energy does the worst and
somehow something that I tried on the
side like blows up and it's incredible
and that's why I reconcile myself done
recognizing if I'm putting my best foot
forward and I'm working strategically
and effectively the things that are
going to work will work and it may not
be the things I expect and what we're
doing is or what I do sometimes too is
you're so focused on wanting one thing
to work you miss the fact that there's
like nine other things that are
happening that are amazing around you
that you could never have dreamed of and
I've seen that in my life countless
times where I wanted one thing to work
three things were working over here but
I was so like why is this not working
like why is this not working that you
missed that so self-doubt for me is
something that I've tried to build a
close relationship with and I get it all
the time I still get it before a post
before a video before anything I mean I
was just in you know I'm working on my
book right now I just launched a podcast
and before I launched the podcast I had
no idea how well it was going to do how
badly it was going to do or anything and
there was a part of me that was like are
people going to listen to this like are
people gonna care like I asked myself
all those questions still today
number one I'm glad I asked myself those
questions it means I'm human it means
that I care it means that it's important
to me I speak at so many conferences and
everyone always asks me do you still get
nervous I go yes I get nervous because I
care the day I stop feeling nervous that
means I don't care anymore if I don't
care anymore that means I don't love
what I do anymore so for me the first
thing is I recognize that self-doubt
just shows me that I care and that
something's important to me whereas I
don't doubt myself around things that I
don't care about like if you ask me a
question right now about what's the
recipe for this amazing dish I wouldn't
know and I'd say I don't know and I'd be
okay with it because I don't care about
cooking I'm not a cook right but if it's
something that you care about you'll
have self-doubt the second thing that I
do with self-doubt is I go okay if
that's the things that I'm doubting
myself for
what strategies what can I put into
place to overcome them doubt is just a
great way of making you check
what you need to work on so if my doubt
is oh my God not enough people are going
to listen to this so I'm like okay so
how do we make it more listenable how do
we make the content better how do we
make the conversation better if my doubt
is
um you know I don't feel like people are
gonna like this topic okay what themes
am I good at talking about what is you
know it's it's a great checking system
to improve what you have so don't look
at self-doubt as negative turn it into a
positive by actually asking yourself
those questions right so build a
relationship with self-doubt because
it's never going to go away right don't
avoid it don't avoid it definitely don't
avoid it it's never going to go away so
if it's never going to go away build a
happy positive relationship with it so
my positive relationship with it is
you're showing me what I need to focus
on to feel less of that and most of us
feel self-doubt because we're not
researching we're not building knowledge
we're not building expertise and I think
that's the biggest thing for me is when
I feel self-doubt it's because I do I'll
give a perfect example
when I was
thinking about doing a podcast and
you're doing interviews
you don't just become an interviewer you
have to watch interviews you have to
absorb good interviewers you've you
can't just be an interviewee you have to
watch good interviewees and so for me a
lot of us start something and we feel
self-doubt because we've never learned
that skill or we've never observed that
skill so my focus is if I want to be a
good interviewer I need to watch good
interviewers if you want to be a good
stage performer watch good stage
performers if you want to be a good monk
watch good monks right you don't become
something good without seeing it so
self-doubt comes because you haven't
upskilled and the great thing today is
you can do an online course you can
upskill from here you can upskill from
there you can just listen to this
podcast and watch you guys who've done
it for such a long period of time that's
a seeing someone who's done something
consistently that's the best way of
getting good at something and then your
self-doubt will disappear so self-doubt
can only be cut by the sword of
knowledge it can only be cut by the
sword of upskilling so that's where it
starts right love is a doing word it's
active it's a verb and if love is a verb
then Services the action and that's why
love and service have to be so
intertwined because I feel that today
when we talk about love the definition
is so skewed when people hear the word
love what the problem is that's what the
problem is that's why I prefer service
to love because service is the
activation of love when someone loves
someone they serve that's how love works
and I think that's why when we talk
about love I agree it's just because of
phonetics definitions breaking it down
love has become so
badly abused like the word love is so
abused and misused in our lives it
really is right you say I love you to
people you don't love people use it to
manipulate people we just throw love
around right and as much as it should be
everywhere
it's also sacred Love's also sacred and
that's why you were able to experience
it because it was experienced through a
sacred mechanism you're able to
experience love yeah and I and I've
never felt it like that before because
it also was this sense of self-love as
well yeah and that's what you felt in
Jerusalem too when you went and that's
what I felt and and that's what I feel
that we experience love when it's
through service and engagement in that
atmosphere we don't just experience it
every single day I'm personally also
having become a I feel like I've become
even more of a Seeker since being
involved and that's opened me up to
alternative ideas alternative ways of
thinking learning from all different
Traditions wherever I can and and I
think that's a really important part I
think the challenge with being a
immature Seeker in my definition of it
is you find something it sounds cool and
you go that's it there's nothing else
and then a real Seeker goes well that is
it but how can everything else even
enhance this and make this even greater
for me if this is where my faith is or
this is where my belief system is so I'm
someone who genuinely loves learning
from people from all different walks of
life and backgrounds because I feel
if I was presented with a deeper more
meaningful philosophy and life structure
I would adopt it
that's why because I'm open to that we
were left on the streets for 30 days to
offend for ourselves and to figure it
out just that's it you've got your
clothes that you're wearing there's no
money no food no shelter no nothing
figure it out
and day one I'm like okay like you know
maybe it's a joke like maybe maybe
they're gonna come back at night and be
like no guys you know so I'm trying to
figure out what it is this is training
mode and it's really interesting what
what your mind and body does so the
first thing your mind and body does when
you have nothing is you have fear
first thing you feel is fear
and that we can all relate to in life
the first thing you feel when you all of
a sudden feel that your plan and you
have no nothing organized and you have
no structure and shelter and all of this
stuff that we now rely on you have fear
now the fact that you're there on your
own and you don't have a phone and you
can't just call someone up and you don't
know the city that you're in
your next thing is survival right fear
leads to survival mode so you're trying
to find food from everywhere you're
trying to hoard it you're trying to get
it from everywhere you're trying to keep
it you're trying to figure out like how
can I get lots of this so that I can
take care of myself and you start just
becoming crazy almost and it's funny
because those two experiences are so
similar to what you see in society today
yeah fear breed survival mode which
breeds greed and hoarding and wanting to
have abundance acts of abundance exactly
and so you do that in that scenario for
like remember this is a 30-day
experiment that's crazy so you do that
for like the first week
you do that for the first week where
you're just trying to find anywhere
steel look Etc not steel try not to
steal but like finding fruits of trees
whatever you're just trying to do
whatever you can finding anywhere to
sleep and you're fending for yourself
it's all about you
the interesting thing that happens in
week two is that you recognize that
you recognize that you really want
to
when you make a difference in someone's
life they'll help you so by week two you
start recognizing if I help villagers if
I help this old lady if I help this old
man if I serve the people around me then
they'll give it to me anyway and we saw
people inviting us into their homes we
saw people giving us food we saw people
cooking for us just because we were
helping people wow and you start to see
Community you start to see the value of
collaboration you start to see the value
of energy exchange you start to learn
how your heart and soul leads to other
people giving you their heart and soul
and and you experience that now the
interesting thing is that goes on for
about two weeks and you think you've
kind of mastered it right and then the
biggest challenge comes when this is
what you're meant to grow to and this is
where you go beyond feeling good about
serving and getting an exchange and this
is not spoke about as permanent today
because I think we live in a world where
people aren't self-loved and self-fueled
enough to even consider this and so we
talk a lot about self-love today which I
highly believe in we talk a lot about
non-judgment of yourself today which I
highly believe in but this principle is
beautiful we recognize by the final week
that actually we were far stronger and
capable than a lot of people on the
planet a lot of people in the village
sorry that were disabled that couldn't
see that had lost their eyesight they
couldn't speak they couldn't walk they
had broken Limbs and so by the end of it
we realized that when we served others
and gained we could actually give to
those people because they didn't have
because they weren't young men like we
were they weren't able men like we were
they weren't skilled like we were and
now you can even go another you can go
another level it wasn't just that you
could take yourself you could go another
level but those three stages of
transformation show us exactly the three
stages we need the first is getting over
your greed and ego the second one is
recognizing that you have value and when
you serve others there's a value
exchange and the third when you're
feeling full and overflowing you can
then overflow to others
and so for me that 30 days like has
transformed my life ever since because I
was able to experience all of the
experiences we experienced today but in
heightened mode like I didn't know where
I was going to sleep or I was going to
eat
and and when you experience it at that
extreme and you're able to work it out
now in with you have more perspective
you have more gratitude you have more
ability to navigate that emotion again
and you recognize that it is an emotion
so for me that was one of the most
transformative things that I've ever
done wow that's powerful yeah and it
just really took me on an internal
journey of overcoming fear overcoming
greed and always recognizing that you
can always go
that one step above and recognizing that
you don't you know as soon as you think
you figured it out recognize that you
haven't and that there can be another
level and I think for all of us that's a
great reminder for me that when I think
I have it figured out that's the biggest
reminder of there's still another level
you've got I think on a personal level I
value deep thought because I loved rap
music so I used to listen to a lot of
rap music growing up and so people like
Tupac Eminem Nars
Etc they're lyrical abilities and their
lyrical expression was a huge part of me
growing up and I used to spend a lot of
time writing lyrics myself and playing
with words and I always enjoyed
expressing things through poetry or
spoken word and when I read these books
a lot of them felt like poetry and
spoken word there were a lot of not just
rhyme but there was a lot of creative
expression there so I almost
was very interested or intrigued because
of the way the philosophy was being
communicated but I wouldn't say I was
looking for or seeking or any of that
sort I was just like oh this is
impressive this is interesting thought
maybe I can apply it in my music or
maybe I can use it here it was less
about the search for knowledge or wisdom
it was more about oh this could be cool
to talk about here or this would be
interesting to extract from and when did
it begin to change when did your
attitude towards a theological texts or
great uh Spiritual Works change from a
kind of
utilitarian curiosity it could be
magpied into hold on a minute there's
something in here that's gonna alter me
so I think the big thing for me was the
the first time I met a monk and it's
something that you can usually you can't
ask someone like when was the first time
you met a month
God I was just a slip of a girl then
back in Kent picking apples on the coast
like also tell me what was your what was
your first experience so I remember I
was around 18 years old 17 18 years old
and I found out from a friend that this
monk had been invited to speak at a
university and I was pretty uninterested
to go I didn't wasn't really fascinated
by it and I actually remember saying to
my friend as long as we go out
afterwards I'll turn up to the event so
we go to a bar as usual dragged even to
the feet of a monk by lust yeah
literally and so he said yeah I promise
you and he was getting into spirituality
and interested by these things so I went
along
and I was captivated who was it so this
man's name is garangadas he lives in
India he's I think you might have met
him at the Eco Village so he built the
Eco Village so you might have met him
when you went there in Mumbai and then
by the Krishna Consciousness Eco village
where it's like 100 carbon footprint
free they grow their own fruit fruit and
veg using let's face it human poo like
like I said those animals there they're
growing fragrant flowers it's sort of
amazing plays it's sort of beautiful
isn't it especially you're like me
thinking what systems could we replicate
in order to save the world absolutely
and that seems like one so you met so I
met him again so he came to he was
speaking and just just to put in context
for everyone listening this man is
Indian he has a strong Indian accent
he's not necessarily externally
attractive to the kind of person I'd be
attracted to at that time I was
attracted to Tupac yeah exactly women
right and Rags to Riches stories I loved
celebrities and influences and people
who'd made money like that's who I
looked up to people who had gone from
nothing to something and then I'm here
listening to this man wearing robes and
I'm totally captivated I'm just like wow
he's so fascinating and the reason that
he was fascinating is because he was
talking about selfless service and he
talked about how real meaning real
happiness real fulfillment from Life
comes when you're able to plant trees
under whose shade you do not plan to sit
so you want to give shelter to others
you want to provide things for others
without expecting something back from
them and at that time that idea just
penetrated through my whole being why
why when it's directly contradictory to
your experience up to that point why is
this message relevant so I think two
things one thing is I was looking for a
thrill in my teens and that's when I was
getting involved in all sorts of wrong
ideas wrong activities or wrong in the
sense of things that we wouldn't
recommend or want our children to give
me drug sex fighting totally yeah all of
that violence
um petty theft all that kind of stuff
and I wasn't doing it because I wanted
stuff I was doing it because I wanted a
thrill in life and when I saw him and
saw the way he was living
he had made that process thrilling like
he looked happy he looked more happy
more content more fulfilled than anyone
I'd ever seen on top of that he was
extremely charismatic
and and I just thought I want to get to
know this man and then I found out that
he'd given up jobs at some of the
biggest companies in the world and he
went to IIT and had studied at IIT which
is the MIT of India the Indian Institute
of Technology he was like a gold
medalist at this place and he'd given
that all up to be a monk to serve
Humanity
and I thought wow that's that's
unbelievable because he's given up
everything that everyone that I know is
chasing
but he's happy and he's found meaning
and he's found that fulfillment that I
feel is just emanating from who he is so
it was the first time in my life where
I'd gone from not looking up to someone
who went from nothing to something but
someone had gone from something to
nothing and and I and that was a massive
Paradigm Shift moment for me and a
massive moment of just wow there is more
out there and and I constantly say this
and I say often it's you can't be what
you can't see I would not have wanted to
be a monk if I didn't see a monk who was
fulfilled and happy and had had this
power about him and up until that point
anyone that I'd seen that was rich or
successful or beautiful or had a
beautiful looking model girlfriend or
whatever it was they still didn't
emanate that happiness for me so I'd saw
that very early on not in the extreme
sense I didn't have celebrity friends or
anything but from what I saw I could
very clearly see that material things
weren't making people deeply happy and
he was someone who had given that up and
seemed happy to me there's a beautiful
Indian story about a musk deer with a
really powerful lesson now you may have
already heard of musk maybe because it
exists in your perfumes or your
aftershaves or deodorants as a scent and
this scent is one of the most expensive
natural products in the world fetching
three times its weight in gold now when
this deer comes across this Aroma
descent
be captivated it searches through the
forest day and night for the source of
this scent completely Intoxicated by
this incredible fragrance the deer
searches in every corner in every place
to find where it's coming from
idea completely exhausted itself looking
for the source with the bitter irony and
not recognizing that the fragrance comes
from inside its own body the fragrance
mask is produced in a gland in the
deer's body the deer spends its whole
life searching for outside what was
always hidden inside
I heard this example when I lived as a
monk to describe the human condition of
life how we spend our whole lives
looking for pleasures and happiness
outside of us
actually what we're searching for is
right there inside of us we tried to
find joy and happiness and external
Pleasures in things in results when
actually real happiness comes from
meaning relationships and a connection
with oneself see we all know that we
can't love someone we don't know so how
can you love yourself when you don't
know yourself and just as this musk dear
we've probably had similar experiences
how many times have you walked out of
your home and then felt that you've
forgotten one of those top three things
usually your keys your wallet or purse
or your phone you rush back in you look
around your own home you make a mess you
make Havoc you look
seat every corner
and then realize
that that phone that wallet or purse or
those keys were in your back pocket in
the process of seeking happiness
externally we make a complete mess of
our minds and life and sometimes even
the lives of others not realizing that
what we were truly looking for has
always been with us today we hear a lot
about self-love and self-care but either
of these
without self-knowledge without
self-realization without self-awareness
remember if we don't know ourselves we
can't love ourselves I remember and this
is like one of those moments I remember
being 10 years old in the school
playground the cutest girl at school had
just found out that I fancied her like
every other guy at school liked her and
I remember a group of girls standing
behind me in the playground just taking
the mick out of me and taking the fun
out of me saying oh how can Jay think
that he could be with her because he's
so ugly and fat and all the rest of it
and and and I look back at them I'm so
happy it happened because I think it's
it's let me be more compassionate let me
be more empathetic it's let me not be
egotistical it's it's humbled me and
made me more grateful and realize how
much hard work it is being any different
anyway that we are and so more accepting
of reality so I'm not upset about it at
all it's something that I think helped
me our identity should stop with
unlearning everything that we think we
know about ourselves okay and how do we
unlearn so the best method of unlearning
is this first and I'm gonna get a really
strategic and tactical because I think
that people need to know what to do
rather than a concept the first thing
you do is write down everything you
currently are chasing in your life make
a lot of goals your dreams your goals
your dreams accomplishments anything
that you're currently chasing and
pursuing okay write them down you can
write down three you can random five you
can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are second line ask
yourself what is the source of that
where did you get that idea did you get
that idea from a TV show you saw did you
get that idea from your parents did you
get that idea from your mom and your dad
your sister your cousin did you get that
idea because your friend just got
proposed to on Instagram did you get
that idea because your friend just got
promoted did you get that idea because
you just broke up right or did you get
an idea because you just feel it when
you do it that you feel alive give me a
specific example that you had when you
were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing and
where it came from absolutely so my my
goal when I was young was to be an
investment banker and when I really
asked myself where did that come from it
came because in my community small
community in London the most successful
person financially was an investment
banker so I believed you had to be an
investment banker to be successful right
so when I asked myself that question
where does that come from it comes from
society's version of success not mine
and then the third thing you ask
yourself is well then what is mine what
is coming from inside of me and if you
just do that three-step process now what
you're doing is you're filtering out the
noise and you're starting to listen to
your voice the thing is you've got a
voice inside of you but it's quiet it's
like it's like Jay like take note of me
like Lewis like you know and it's just
like trying to get through and the noise
of everyone else's opinions is so loud
so this way you filter it we always been
trained to focus on the results so
people ask what do you want in life I'm
like forget that that's the worst
question to ask someone because when you
ask what you want that's when the ads
come in and you're like oh I want that
car I want that home I want that dress I
want that body I want whatever it is
I my question to you is what do you want
to wake up and be every day like what do
you want to wake up and do every day
what's the process that you're in love
with
so we're thinking about the result
whereas my question is forget the result
what's the process that you're in love
with doing
so start there first of all don't start
your journey of saying I want to be a
movie director because I want to you
know I want to hit the Blockbuster chart
so I want to do this don't make it about
that like don't don't be like I want to
be a singer because I want to be Ariana
Grande Right like that's not the point
that's just a result
do you love singing every day and I
realize this with a very honest question
to myself I'm really passionate about
football soccer I absolutely love the
game I grew up on it I'm still a huge
fan I missed out on it when I was a monk
I've been catching up ever since like
I'm like oh any football game I was just
in London last week and I made sure I
went I didn't couldn't see a game live
but I went and watched it at a bar in
London and I love the energy I'm so
passionate about soccer
don't have what it takes to be a soccer
player yeah like I do not want to wake
up at 4am I wake up at 4am to meditate
when I was a monk I wake up at 6 00 5 30
a.m now to meditate
I do not want to wake up at 4am to go
out on a raining pitch and Play Soccer
like I don't want to be in the gym for
four hours a day I want to meditate for
four hours a day but I don't want to
play soccer for four hours a day and
then be in the gym and train I'm not
envious of any athlete in the world
because it takes a different type of
mindset I really believe that everything
we say that beautiful thought from
Gandhi where he said that when what you
think what you say and what you do are
in line then you'll experience Harmony
and and I've really taken that to heart
and it's it's this powerful spiritual
principle and it really makes you think
what you say and what you do are aligned
and so for me any form of language any
form of your emotional vocabulary is
building your mental reality and I think
people forget that their vocabulary is
defining their life you are creating
your life on a daily basis by the words
you use so for me and I'm not saying
that I feel that way about everyone else
I'm saying that's how I feel about that
word someone may say oh when I say I
swear with it it makes me laugh for me
it doesn't that I would only swear when
I felt bad and I felt something negative
towards something so for me that had
negative emotions negative connotations
and negative uh intention attached to it
so I wanted to remove anything from my
vocabulary that I felt was negative so
even as simple as and I've done this
very recently but it changed my life
instead of me saying I'm busy or it's
been a busy week I say I'm having a
productive week and I feel different
when I go to bed just by that simple
change I go to bed thinking yeah I've
had a really productive day today rather
than God I had a busy day today like I
don't want to wake up tomorrow I'm going
to have a busy day tomorrow and so that
simple emotional vocabulary change is
just catapulted my mind into feeling
excited and enthusiastic all the time I
was really shy I didn't enjoy stages I
didn't enjoy speaking my parents forced
me to go to public speaking and drama
school so I spent 14 to 18 in public
speaking drama school changed my life I
did not know what I wanted to speak
about so even when I finished at 18 I
still didn't like going on stage because
I didn't have anything to talk about so
now you've got the tools but you haven't
got the passion so I developed somewhat
of an expertise in four years but I
didn't have what I was passionate about
and when I became a monk
I was like this is it this is why I went
to public speaking school because I love
talking about philosophy I love talking
about science I love talking about
culture I love talking about life I love
talking about growth Etc the mind so I
got what I was passionate about when I
became a monk so for me the process came
from four years of consistent public
speaking school like it changed my life
and and that's all thanks to my parents
for forcing me to go I had no interest
in being a public speaker or a
Storyteller any of these things that was
just I lucked out and then it was me
finding what I was passionate to speak
about and then I've spoken I've spoken
for three hours a day for the last 13
years
and I spoke to audiences of zero all the
way to audiences now of thousands but
when I first started speaking I remember
I was invited to speak at a university
where I wasn't getting paid for I was
like 20 years old I was invited to speak
to this University no one showed up
twice so they organized two events for
me I was meant to speak about life
philosophy Etc all the kind of stuff I
speak about now and zero people turned
up and I practiced my speech both times
to an empty room as if it was a packed
room because I was like I'm still going
to practice and so for me having done
this for three hours a day for the last
13 years that's now being gratefully
received online so I'm very fortunate
that it's shifted from an offline world
to an online World which we can dive
into yeah but the point is it's it's
been my absorption and addiction for
like feet for over a decade now one of
the biggest mistakes we make is that we
confuse inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if I've
never spoken on a stage I just think oh
I'm probably not good at that or if I've
never played golf I'd probably think oh
I'm probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method I can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days and get really
tactical every single day that's why
you're playing tennis a lot right now
yeah
take the eight days go join a course an
online course or Workshop go and Shadow
a friend go to a seminar a conference go
to reading a book listen to a podcast go
and expose yourself to eight different
things in a month eight different things
eight different things in a month and
guess what in a month you will have
learned what you probably would have
learned in eight years because most of
us test one new thing a year maybe maybe
if that exactly right like some people
don't even do that but if you do eight
different things in a month and this is
how you have to see it if you went to
eight different restaurants in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like I had that burrito or I had that
taco did I like it right the first
question you ask yourself is did I gotta
try it first you're gonna try it first
you're gonna go to the restaurant yeah
there's no point so you're gonna say did
I like it the second question you ask
yourself is why did I or why did I not
like it like why is so important I think
too many people just go I like it or I
don't like it why didn't I like it and
the third question you have to ask
yourself really really simple is do I
want to do it again and if you do that's
where you start uncovering is so my
point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification in the hope for money in
the Hope For Success we end up chasing
the wrong things and we make a mess we
end up with less than we started with
end up with more issues than we
bargained for whilst climbing that
ladder and that stairway we forget why
we started climbing in the first place
once the king of Bhutan was asked by an
interviewer what the GDP of Bhutan was
he was Rising shocked he replied by
saying in Bhutan we don't just measure
the GDP we measure the GNH instead of
just measuring the gross domestic
product
measure gross national happiness in the
process of getting older we forget the
real goal of life if you could make a
little less and spend more time doing
what you love would that make you
happier don't trade your happiness for
what you think you need things can never
make us happy because they're temporary
and limited but experiences can last
forever too many people are working hard
on things they don't love to spend money
they don't have to buy things they don't
need to impress people they don't like
when we create our identity around what
we do a career a job an occupation we
can never be happy because we're basing
it on something external but when we
create an identity around who we are and
what we want to be and become then
anything is possible and remember we
become successful by what we get but we
become Happy by what we give don't get
the too confused I start off the chapter
with this beautiful thought from Charles
Horton Cooley and I love telling it
because it's just it's just the best and
I think it was written in like the 1900s
and he said today the challenge is I'm
not what I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am it's crazy and it's like it blows my
mind every time I say it gives me the
chills like I feel it and the reason why
I start with identity is because I think
that's the root of all our challenges
and the first step to thinking like a
monk is starting at the root not
starting at the symptoms or The
Superficial or the surface level but
let's go to the root if you're playing a
role if you're wearing a mask if you're
dressed in clothes that are not yours
then you end up living a life that's not
yours and in the book I give this
example of method acting yes yeah I'm a
massive movie junkie and I love method
actors so people like Heath Ledger of
course from The Dark Knight series
you've got Jared Leto so Jared Leto when
he played the Joker in this is not in
the book in Suicide Squad he used to
send dead rats in the mail to his
co-star he did because he was trying to
get into the mindset of how someone that
perverted would behave and then Daniel
Day Lewis when he was filming for Gangs
of New York he's actually wearing these
coats that are centuries old so that he
can get into character one he's off
camera yeah when he can feel it right
he's not wearing watches he's not
carrying around his mobile phone they're
speaking in the accents and he talks
about how he actually went crazy because
guess what when you fake being someone
for so long
you think it's your reality and that's
what happens to all of us we play a role
at work we play a role at home we play a
role with our family we play a role in
our friends and then we think that role
is us right and we lose ourselves and to
me that is the core reason why we're
chasing things that are not important to
us the Envy actually is more of a
expression of how we feel about
ourselves rather than how we're
perceiving someone else it's actually so
much more about how comfortable we feel
with who we are how confident who we
feel with who we are how much
self-esteem we have and myself Assurance
we have Envy is more a root of that than
it is of the fact that someone else is
doing well it's less about the fact that
someone out there is amazing Making
Waves doing something that you want to
be doing it's more about how we feel
about ourselves and it's experienced in
that way of looking at someone else and
reflecting back on us Social Circles
family circles someone else has done
amazingly in the exam someone just
landed a new job someone else has got
promoted and everyone's looking at you
going what are you doing right what have
you achieved where where are you today
where have you got right what's
happening with you tell us about you and
you're thinking you know you're going
through all your head you're trying to
come up with all the things that you've
thought about all the things that you've
achieved all the things that you've done
and you're trying to bring it up like
constantly but you're struggling you
find it hard because you're now
measuring your growth based on someone
else's you're now measuring your success
based on someone else's and that is the
biggest challenge with Envy the one of
the biggest challenges it brings in our
life is that it forces us to start
measuring our sex sorry our success in
comparison to someone else's that is the
biggest challenge with Envy when we
start comparing the level of our success
with someone else's you're already on
the wrong foot I think any sorts of
dress or any sort of
whether it be yeah dress or appearance
or any of that if it's taking you away
from who you actually are and how you
like expressing yourself then then that
kind of contradicts being able to be
authentic and being real so that I feel
more authentic wearing this than I did
wearing my robes when I was a month
literally use your weekends and evenings
to do a test on anything
the best way is go into a course test it
out try doing it once go and Shadow
someone who does it someone in your life
that does it if you want to be a
podcaster come and Shadow you guys for a
week right and see what that life's like
see what it actually looks like to
research to sit with a guest to find new
guests to work it out like go and Shadow
someone who's already doing it and then
try and do it for a day like try and do
the schedule of someone you look up to
for a day like if you can do that for a
day and you loved it then do it for one
more day and if you loved it do it for
another day and that's going to trickle
in so that's a much smarter way to
finding your passion rather than just
sitting there and reflecting which is
cool which is important but I'd
encourage you to just get out there
right get out there and live the life of
someone who's doing it when they started
that's another Point don't focus on what
people are doing now focus on what they
were doing when they started so a lot of
people ask me they're like Jay how many
videos do you make a week I'm like I
make three videos a week plus my podcast
on top of that plus Instagram and
they'll say oh wow that's too much and I
was like yeah but when I started
you know go back to that how boring
would it be to live in a world where
everyone was just like us imagine if
everyone in your life talked like you
thought like you walk like you the world
would be a boring Place there'd be no
new cultures to explore no new languages
to learn no new adventures to be had if
while you're writing your book if while
you're recording your podcast if you're
sitting there going I hope this is going
to be number one this better be number
one I hope I sell more copies than this
person who's launching at the same time
because that's the only way well guess
what now the quality of your output
right now has just dropped because guess
what you're now living 75 in the future
and you're 25 right now and guess what
this 25 is going to Define that future
goal and result and your happiness and
you're happy whether you get the result
or not totally whereas for me when I was
writing my book and of course I want my
book be a best-selling book of course I
want my podcast to do well of course we
don't do anything for it to be lost like
no one does that but what I do know is
that when I'm creating when I'm
producing when I'm writing
that's all I'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent of the world's
population can multitask now the crazy
thing is when two percent when people
hear that they think I'm in that
okay they're in there but most of us are
the 98 yeah and the truth is there is no
such thing as multitasking what it is is
fast switching between two tasks so the
quality is just dropping because you can
actually you cannot do two things at one
time you cannot no one genuinely can do
two things at once I guess you could
maybe like Pat your head and do this and
say yeah yeah you can't do something
productive at the same time right or
creative and so what I'm saying is that
when you're sitting here going this
needs to be number one you are reducing
that thing's ability to be number one
because it now doesn't have your full
Focus right so so that's the Difference
Maker that you can want to be number one
there's nothing wrong with that but you
can't keep comparing what number one is
to someone else's goal too because
everyone's got a different trajectory
like there are some people that are kind
of come in and do really well at one
thing and you're going to do really well
at another and that's why competition
has to First be in your space like don't
compete in a space that's not yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get lost
their identity
I'd literally experimented with
everything with my health even as a monk
and I tried week-long fasts and I'd
pushed myself without sleep basically
about four to six hours a night and I
got to a point where I was like I need
to take care of my health I need to make
my health a priority because I was so
fascinated about mastering the mind that
I almost neglected the needs of the body
and I can definitely say that I got to
incredible places with my mind but at
the expense of sacrificing my caretaking
of my body and I felt I wanted to go
back and do both of them together and so
a lot of my friends will say Jay you
always look like you've got something
exciting going on in life and I'm like
yeah I do but that's because like nine
people told me that my other ideas
sucked right and so like I've I get more
wins because I get more failures because
I'm failing so often I'm trying so many
things out so often that don't go right
and that everyone sees the one thing
that goes right and that's how it works
and that's the odds for anyone that's
not just me anyone who's doing what they
love every day is trying a hundred
different things and most of them are
not working but because they're playing
the game of numbers
something's got to work like that's how
I live I'm just like if I try 10 things
this year one of them's got to work but
if I try one thing this year most likely
it probably won't work right and that's
the biggest challenge if we just up our
experiments like you're gonna you know
do something new for every weekend this
year the way I see it is that
competition in and of itself is not good
or bad and and this is like the monk
mindset on 99 of things that this mug is
not good or bad it can be filled with
water or it could be filled with poison
yes and so competition I'll give you an
example as monks our competition is and
how much love and respect we show to
each other that's your conversation
that's what you compete on or how long
can we meditate
longer than you so if any Monk Is it and
I did this plenty of times really if I
sat there and I thought oh yeah look at
him he's scratching his back he got out
like this your meditation just got
destroyed all the value and so monks
will never ask how long you meditate
okay they focus on how deep you meditate
and someone who meditates deep doesn't
go on about how deep it was but but you
compete for showing respect you compete
for serving each other you compete for
how well you can collaborate and I feel
like you live this yes like I I feel
like you have that you used to do that
yeah
you think like a month like I feel like
we're always trying to find a way where
we can be better friends to each other
and support each other and so you're
competing on that and and that's a
positive competition that I think you
can have so you can still use and this
is the beautiful thing about the monk
mindset you can use any yeah thing in a
positive way everyone you love and
respect and look up to
that's been their path and I think
that's what's given me so much that's
what's liberated me from it like Steve
Jobs is one of my biggest role models in
in certain areas of his life and when
I've read his autobiography his
biography Sorry by Walter Isaacson
it's failed so many times yet all of us
like most of us have a phone that's an
iPhone or an Apple product in our home
or whatever it is it's like he's not
worried about all those times that went
wrong because he obviously won big in
this area of his life so my take's just
everyone you look up to whether it's an
athlete an entrepreneur or a coach a CEO
whatever it is they have messed up so
many times
just know that so when you're messing up
you're on the path like you're on the
same path right and and I yeah I
encourage people to share what they're
failing at too because it just helps
something that happens is you have to
surround yourself by peers in a space
too who understand you and don't see you
as competition and that's really hard
and it's like a fine line I genuinely
believe that collaboration wins always
so I my whole approach to most things
has always been hey I want to
collaborate with you whether I'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media I'm just like I just want to work
together because I think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success and numbers but
more in terms of I want to be friends
with you and so I reach out regularly to
people that I admire in different ways
and I reach out to them and say hey I'd
love to get to know you I'd love to
learn from you I'd love to connect I'd
love to be a friend like not I'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this and
if that comes naturally from that
relationship I may amazing if it never
evolves into that I've just got a great
friend who now gets me so I try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
I feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do are just so great because they
already get you right and uh someone
that I had on my podcast lately her name
is Lily Singh Superwoman she's become a
recent friend she's been incredibly and
is incredibly successful on social media
she's using a platform for doing amazing
good in the world and she was someone I
reached out to because I was just like
hey like you've been doing all of this
for a while you start on YouTube a lot
longer than I did and I would just love
to connect from you and hear from you
and she's become an incredible friend
and we've just been sharing ideas and
learning together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time I'm trying to find people who
are not in media so I still have
friendships with the monks back in India
and I just spent January in India for a
month I was meditating again for for
roughly about 21 days and I have them in
my life because they remind me of like
the roots and they remind me of the
truths that bring me back
so I kind of like both I love people who
totally get my space and usually those
are people I reach out to and then I
love having my roots down so most of my
inner circle now is from people I've
reached out to or they become people
who've been reaching out to me for a
long long time and have been
consistently reaching out to me asking
for nothing I'd say I was quite
rebellious and independent even as a
monk a lot of part of amongst life is
conforming and accepting Authority and
following a path and those are all
beautiful things for people who who like
those things for me it was a great
training ground and a great system of
giving me abilities and skills and
habits that I didn't have before but
then I really felt a deep calling in my
heart to want to share this in a
specific way so I I kind of feel dragged
to do what I do now because it's so
deeply in me to want to make things
relevant non-sectarian Universal and
accepting of all truths and paths it's
just it's just there and I can't ignore
it and I got to a point in my monk life
where I just felt like I can't ignore or
this desire to want to go and spread
this wisdom and insight in a way
independently in a way that I feel will
work and help people you know from an
impact point of view and so that was a
big part of it the challenge is that we
think things
come with emotions feelings we think
things come with feelings and emotions
and guess what they don't so if you
chase money well they might for a moment
right or they won't I don't think they
even do also it's such a false sense of
feeling I don't maybe for a moment but
it's so short-lived that it's it's not
even worth counting almost so it's like
when you when you think that I'm chasing
money guess what you will get money yeah
and that's great money is really
important and money is a really
important resource but guess what money
is not now Gonna Fill that Gap that void
that feeling that emotion that you're
missing in your life what are most
people missing we're missing a deep
sense of love I think I think the
biggest need in the world as we've heard
many times before from all the ancient
texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling a false sense of Love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing What We crave
in life is what we did or didn't get
from our parents what our parents did
give us is what we continue to Crave or
what they didn't give us is what we
continue to Crave so you'll find that
most people's love languages that they
chase are things that their parents
didn't give them so if their parents
didn't give them time they now crave
everyone's time if their parents didn't
give them gifts they'd crave gifts if
their parents didn't give them acts of
service they'd be craving those acts of
service so it's because of our childhood
and if we don't learn to process all of
that experience which most people never
get the time to do and I empathize with
that because I've had to go through that
I've seen me repeating my parents
patterns I've seen the thing you were
craving so I would crave a big thing for
me was I would crave surprises and gifts
because that's your thing yeah that's my
thing it's still my thing yeah and and I
did your parents not do that for you no
they did my mom did a lot of it that's
why you're still crazy correct so my mom
would always every year on my birthday
she'd always surprise me with the one
thing I wanted and I wasn't spoiled
growing up I didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a Power Rangers toy
or whether it's whatever it was you know
something video game yeah thing is you
want as a kid right and she would always
surprise me with that and that became so
deep rooted now I'll give you an example
when I then married my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're gonna do the same thing Tony you
can do that no because I'm expecting my
wife to be like my mom in the sense of I
expected a surprise or show me love in
the same way and she doesn't know that
she's not mind reader I can't explain
expect her to know that so it took
communication it took time for me to
explain that so anyway I think that's
where it stems from that desire it
doesn't come from any you can say it
comes from society and education of
course it does but I think the deepest
place it comes is what your parents did
or didn't give you that's that's where
it comes from now I've seen some stories
about some phenomenal paralympians I've
seen some phenomenal stories about human
beings who without arms and legs have
achieved extraordinary Feats and this
blows my mind because I always think
like it's some of us have challenges in
different areas but imagine being born
without legs or arms or you know like
actually not having stuff that we all
take for granted but those are like for
some people that would be an absolute
dream to have there now through Robotics
and bionic limbs they can have that but
for years they've lived without it but
still seen I've seen positivity in them
I've seen driving them I've seen a
desire in them to achieve something
phenomenal so it's amazing what's
happening out there we really have to
connect with those stories rather than
living in our small bubble and often
because we only live in our small bubble
we talk to the same people
right one of the biggest challenges with
Envy is that we talk to the same people
and they talk to each other so our group
is so small that we only hear the same
stuff and we kind of start living as if
that bubble of life is real a young boy
once asked his teacher what's the
difference between I like you and I love
you the teacher beautifully answered
well it's like a flower if you like a
flower you pluck it but if you love a
flower you water it and nurture it daily
and watch it grow there is such a thin
line between light and love and because
of it we make so many mistakes in our
relationships when we want something in
the moment we take it
don't think any further we do whatever
we want to get that feeling of pleasure
not realizing that we're neither
Satisfied by that pleasure and nor will
that thing last when we pluck a flower
not only will that flower die but we
can't experience it for any longer than
that moment when you water it and take
care of it daily you can
said forever we've been wired towards an
instant gratification instant pleasure
mindset all of the adverbs that we see
whether they're online or offline are
geared to driving us towards making
instant decisions for instant Promises
of pleasure the catch is not only does
that instant pleasure not satisfy us the
feeling doesn't last we're so used to
seeing all the strap lines and headlines
on the internet learn this language in
five minutes get the ideal body in 10
minutes a day become a millionaire in 12
months now all of these sound brilliant
right the problem is they're not real
they're not true they're false promises
the reason why it works is because it
appeals to one of the most basic human
desires situational Improvement without
major resource investment of course you
can pick up a few words in another
language or shed a few pounds of weight
if that was your goal or maybe you will
make a little bit more money but real
knowledge real awareness real Fitness
real business all of these things take
time real relationships real connection
real purpose takes time naturally the
internet headlines focus on the short
term instead of the long term because
most of us would never click on
something if it said learn a language in
five years with dedicated daily practice
we wouldn't click on something that said
here is the one hour workout that you
need to do every single day and we
wouldn't click on the one that said if
you want to be a millionaire here are
the 10 failures that you'll go through
in year one how broke you might be by
year three and you may not even make it
by year nine the important lesson here
is if you want meaning if you want
purpose if you want fulfillment those
things
time once there was a farmer who worked
extremely hard he worked diligently
every single day to make sure he had the
healthiest crops and the healthiest
Fields as he worked he often looked
towards the opposite Farm
that farm always seemed healthier more
Lush and more green he would often start
to envy that farmer and feel some
jealousy inside of himself
he would sometimes say to himself maybe
they have better land maybe they get
more rain maybe it's because that farmer
has more money from his family or his
parents sometimes he'd say to himself
it's because that farmer has better
tools or better tractors to plow in the
land often he'd think it's because he's
got more help from his children than I
do every day
[Music]
every month every year this farmer was
feeling more and more envious seeing the
lush green healthy abundant land on the
other side he'd constantly wonder and be
trying to figure out why it was that
that farmer had The Greener land till
one day he realized he couldn't stand it
anymore and he was going to go and find
out he made a route with a plan to get
to the other farm he went through the
woods over the hills through Thorns
through bushes to all of these
challenges to get to that side to get to
that farm and then
when he got there he was completely
shocked completely confused he thought
to himself maybe I'm lost
he felt like he was standing on his
ground again he felt like he'd gone
around in a circle and ended up in
exactly the same place he thought this
because when he looked across again to
the other Farm it looked lush green and
healthy and where he was standing seemed
average and normal but when he looked
back over to the other side
he saw his children playing on the farm
he had made it to the other side and
that day he learned an extremely
important lesson he realized after
making it to the farm that he envied the
boss always seems greener on the outside
but then he went one step further he
realized that the grass is not just
green on the other side it's Greener
where you water it and whoever looks for
greener grass on the other side will
never be able to recognize notice or
appreciate the grass that was beneath
their feet the whole entire time because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
if you want another amazing J Shetty
video check it out right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there